I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her and it's not
oh hi mark
I love my eyes I didn't miss anything
that's what what time
jaw's the revenge because apparently I
like talking about total shit and you
guys seem to enjoy watching it so here I
am doing it again welcome back to
another hilarious 'ti review my last one
was Batman and Robin you guys really
enjoy that and he requested me to do
more of these so I'm back talking about
not only one of the worst sequels ever
made
I actually think jaws or revenge is one
of the worst movies ever made but it's
pretty hilarious and awesome and I've
wanted to do a review of jaws 4 for a
long time because Siskel and Ebert did a
video review of this movie and that was
one of the first video reviews that made
me want to do movie reviews so it really
inspired me and I felt the need to bring
my brand of destruction to jaws the
revenge because there's just no stopping
making fun of this movie now I'm not
going to describe the plot of Jaws for
yet until later in this video because
it's by far one of the funniest parts of
this movie and I want to savor it so the
movie opens with the cliched underwater
viewing shot you see the point of view
of the shark and then it comes up over
the water but you can kind of see above
the water as well so it's almost like
you're really the point of view of the
fin because you're seeing what the shark
is seeing but you're seeing above water
but you know what this shark spends the
majority of the movie above water and
cut underneath it so I guess it does
make sense in Jaws the revenge when you
see the shark at the top of the water
you only see its fin drying out and yet
when you get the sharks point of view
like we just look at the people it's
like its eyes are above the water too
that's a logical error among many
logical errors you've got that right
within seconds you know the filmmakers
don't care about you because there's
this horrible sped up shot of Ellen
Brody's hand approaching the fridge
where you can tell they just thought
well she did that too slowly so we're
gonna have to speed that up and post but
it looks like garbage so Ellen Brody is
on a mini island with her son there's
Christmas carolers for some reason this
movie took place during Christmas time
and her son has to go out on the water
of course to clear away some wood that
floated into something and got stuck and
what do you know there's a shark and he
dies in a flurry of cuts and shoppi
editing that are apparently supposed to
tell us that someone's being eaten alive
by a shark but it really just looks like
if you handed a camera to an NFL
quarterback and told him to throw it
into the ocean and then you get that
shot of just like spinning and spinning
and blurry
and then eventually something splashes
in the water you're not entirely sure
what it was
that's Jaws fours way of showing a shark
attack so Ellen Brody's son dies and of
course she's really broken up about it
her other son Michael comes to Amity
Island he's a marine biologist
of course because what else would he do
if it didn't involve water
despite his entire family being
constantly attacked by sharks and within
just five minutes jaws for feels like a
melodramatic soap opera that you'd find
on daytime TV there's nothing about this
movie that tells you it's a summertime
thrill ride this movie is depressing as
hell
gloomy dreary and ugly now I mentioned
the plot earlier and here is where we
get our first little taste of said plot
tainted what its waited all this time
and it came to him apparently this
specific shark came for her son
so Roy Scheider the star of the first
two films was smart enough to say no to
the third one and even smarter to say no
to this one so they killed him off for
some reason that's right
he had a heart attack between movies now
the reason that he had a heart attack
was because of hey come on can't believe
that voodoo chefs don't commit murder
they don't pick out a person hit up Sean
get killed your father
dad dad from a heart attack he died from
fear the fear of it killed him I would
think if anyone on this planet would not
be afraid of sharks it would be the guy
who killed two already so now we get a
little more introduction to Mike Brody
her son the marine biologist character
and during this scene in the middle of
his dialogue he just takes off running
for no apparent reason kids always
wanted to do a house
the only thing I can think of for why
that would happen is the writers all of
a sudden were like oh my god guys we
don't have time to finish the scene just
have it run away seriously is this movie
depressing or what there's someone
crying or moaning or screaming in every
scene so Ellen Brody understandably is
feeling very broken up she already lost
her husband to a heart attack because
he's really afraid of sharks and she
just lost her son to an actual shark
so she's feeling sad and she is
screaming at her son I want you to get
out of the water I want you to give up
that terrible job I don't want anyone in
my family anywhere near the water
never again so guess where she goes in
the very next scene okay okay a boat in
the water so yeah and once again my god
this movie is so sad it's so depressing
who thought jaws the revenge needed to
be a cry fest it's like spider-man three
had a baby with jaws 3 sucked any fun
that was in both of those films out and
it became jaws for the movie where
everyone cries all the time and it's sad
and disgusting and dreary and horrible
so we're watching the movie and things
are happening and what the fuck is
Michael Caine doing in this movie
Michael Caine why are you in this movie
man so Michael Caine collects a paycheck
playing an airline pilot in fact this is
actually known as one of his paycheck
pictures other ones included movies like
the swarm and of course what would any
responsible pilot do to a family that's
just lost a loved one and has all the
remaining members in his own cabin
right
come on man Harrison Ford would be
ashamed Harrison Ford's the man so next
we are greeted with the cheapest most
minut most simple level of thrill
possible in a movie
like they say I'm setting out live I
hate when that happens a dream sequence
people were groaning in the theater when
that happened I mean I want to go up and
punch a hole in the screen now when I
watched the original classic jaws film
and even the alright jaws - and screw it
the hilarious jaws 3 all of those movies
still feel like summer movies because
they all take place during this summer
they still have a vibe of fun infused
into them even the terrible jaws 3 still
feels a little bit warm a little bit
inviting they all feel that way the
choice to place jaws 4 during Christmas
was the most horribly misguided choice
since like hey let's just have diehard 5
just be fucking terrible so finally we
get our first look at the shark please
observe that's it
zero suspense zero ok there's no
suspense it cuts directly to a close-up
of the shark which by the way just
follow them from New York to the Bahamas
the shark followed them from New York to
the Bahamas
now Michael Caine shows up again in this
movie reminding us that he wanted to buy
a nice big house did you know that he
was unable to accept his Oscar win in
person because of his work on this movie
and in another example of the worst
pilot in history take the wheel
no I can't show you Carol I mean I don't
know how yep nobody does delaila
at this point in the movie we are 30
minutes into this film and there has
been no suspense I mean nothing
absolutely nothing it's been a soap
opera the entire time and then finally
something happens the shark shows up and
starts chewing on Mike's boat and during
this scene we get to see Ellen's first
use of her psychic connection with the
shark much wrong
so yeah this random shark is hunting the
Brody family
this shark that apparently is buddies
with the other three sharks is now
hunting the Brody family it's like the
shark was like I don't like you because
you killed my three buddies I'm gonna
travel to the Bahamas I'm gonna I'm
gonna kill the Brody family and I'm
gonna fight all you sons of bitches
because I was shark motherfucker and I'm
gonna find you and you're going down bro
I can't even contain it oh my god that's
the dumbest plot ever in a movie I think
it's the number one dumbest plot in the
movie ever guys I really do
even the tagline of this movie is this
time it's personal and speaking of that
tagline I recall a scene from Jaws - you
don't think that the shark was destroyed
that another shark could could come in
sharks don't take things personally mr.
Boddy
apparently none of the elementary school
writers who wrote this script had seen
jaws - so okay I'll deal with that and
since we're all sitting there watching
this jaws movie hoping for a thrilling
film we want some suspense we want some
entertainment we want to see some shark
action and we want to see some cool
characters involved with said shark
action the filmmakers thought well hey
they don't want any of that we just want
to see these characters wandering around
the city
blah blah blah about random shit and
dancing and guess what they're kind of
go dancing again because that's what we
want to see we want to see these two
middle-aged - slightly older people just
partying that's what we want to do right
now but in a film so stupid with hardly
any real action or any real suspense at
least maybe the dialogue can save it
right I'd always wanted to make love to
an angry welder I've dreamed of nothing
else since I was
nope
so they rigged a tracker and stick it in
the shark that's out for fucking revenge
and we're almost immediately returned to
sad relationship drama and boring
serious family discussions because they
needed to remind us that we were
watching jaws the soap opera and do you
remember how annoying that first dream
sequence was the cheapest possible level
of thrill you can have in a movie now
about the next dream sequence
another is only enhanced and the dream
sequences why do they do that in the
movie if there's anything that annoys an
audience it's the dream sequence I hate
that stunt it's old it's cheap it's a
lousy gimmick and I wish they would stop
doing it in the films most clever
dramatic scene is actually a direct
ripoff of the first Jaws in the first
Jaws Roy Scheider and his son mimicked
each other by touching themselves on the
face it was so cute and so touching the
best jaws 4 can do in regards to drama
is ripoff one of the best scenes in the
first jaws so jaws attacks Mike's boat
and you can tell they always have to
frame the shark with his lower belly out
of shot so they can hide whatever they
use to move him around it's pathetic so
after being attacked directly by the
shark that his own mother has warned him
as hunting their family he gets out of
the water and then two minutes later he
goes right back into the water where he
knows this shark is that wants to eat
him I'm telling you the writers have
completely given up on giving us
compelling reasons for anything to
happen at this point because it's the
fourth film in the franchise they've got
no more ideas and they're assuming they
have a built-in audience that's going to
provide them with funds to continue to
make jaws movies forever so Ellen gets
more psychic readings as jaws approaches
this banana boat with a bunch of kids on
it and eats a woman I'm telling you she
has a psychic connection with the shark
I'm not making this up it's actually in
the movie whenever the shark is nearby
she actually gets up and bolts and looks
out into the ocean like she recognizes
that the shark is there they have a
connection she's like an x-men I'm
telling you it's fucking crazy so she
gets really mad she
deels this boat and goes out into the
ocean on her own what exactly is she
attempting to accomplish she has no gear
no weaponry nothing what is she going to
do against this shark is she going to
throw herself at the shark is she
literally going to jump into the ocean
allow the shark to eat her so that it
can all be over ah this movie just made
me have a short circuit in my neck so
all the characters magically meet up for
the big finale and before Michael Caine
shows up with his airplane to take them
to wherever she is you're telling me
they planned to sail out into the ocean
on that with the giant freaking shark
that can sail across the country so they
find Ellen they crash land their plane
into the ocean and these it is jump into
the water where the man-eating shark is
and swim to the boat and here's Ellen's
explanation for her actions why did you
take a boat realize what you were doing
I had to do it nothing else to do you
shouldn't have done it the shark then
attacks Michael Caine his reaction is
amazing it probably is the best part of
the movie but of course he survives set
attack climbs out of the boat and that
last scene is preceded by one of the
most glaring errors in recent movie
history Michael Caine has been in the
water has swim to safety onto the boat
but in the very next scene his shirt is
as dry as if it just been freshly
laundered it's not even the next shot
Michael Caine actually comes over the
rail out of the water and he's totally
dry I was sitting in a theater and I
said his shirt is dry you know this
preview audience laughs preciate that
you know I always hate it when people
talk during the movies but I don't know
that seemed to go over pretty well yeah
that's right Roger Ebert his shirt is
dry now Michael Caine's apparent
explanation for this was that they took
so long for the next set up to be done
that his shirt dried in the Sun they
couldn't just spray them down with some
water
I mean how easy is that you just take
your in there's a water tank you're in a
water tank right there just take some
water just throw it on them so they
rigged what I call a movie device it's
an object that doesn't actually exist in
real life and thus must be explained to
the audience and
preferably extremely fast so that we
don't question its lunacy they have some
kind of electronic thing that resembles
a flashlight that will obviously
electrocute the shark after he eats it
at the push of a button so they
successfully get this electronic thing
into the shark's mouth as it launches
itself out of the water as I said spends
way more time out of the water than in
it and then pulls this extremely obvious
stunt double down underneath in more
examples of Ellen's incredible psychic
abilities she starts to have flashbacks
to events that she never witnessed in
fact no one witnessed we were the only
people us as the audience who got to see
Roy Scheider blow up a shark we were the
only people who got to see her son be
killed and yet somehow she is able to
recall these memories because she's a
fucking x-man now this is the best part
of the movie I'm telling you guys this
is the best part of the movie there's
nothing on earth better than this the
shark is like balancing on its back fin
okay on top of the water as they zap it
with the electronic thingy and it starts
roaring like a fucking lion I swear to
you it starts growling like a fucking
lion
sharks don't have vocal cords or even
lungs they what happened it roared like
a lie
oh my god fucking locusts that's not the
best part as it balances on its fin she
Rams the boat into it and it explodes
you
it explodes the short blows up for no
reason it blows up oh my god now there
is an uncut ending to this movie and
it's much better apparently it's only
available on like certain cuts of the
movie it was shown on a few TV stations
and I don't know about what country had
it or what country didn't have it but
she rammed the shark in this ending and
she impales it and the shark is like
it's like spraying absurd amounts of
shark blood everywhere and then the
shark breaks off and falls into the
ocean that was a much better ending than
the actual ending we got in the
theatrical cut that steals the exact
shot from the end of the first jaws of
the shark sinking into the ocean they
actually took the exact shot oh yeah and
by the way this dude is still alive
after he was eaten by a shark and then
they were electrocuting said shark and
then it somehow blew up yeah that guy
lived in the next scene they're
magically back on land now they needed a
plane to get out there their boat sank
their plane sank how did they get back
on land I'm telling you I swear this
movie was written by elementary
schoolers in fact you know what that's
what they did Universal took this script
sent it to an elementary school
somewhere and asked all the kids to pass
it around and say hey write down what
you think will be cool in a shark movie
and they all went oh cool yeah well I'd
like to see a guy fly around and do
stunts okay there you go well I think a
shark should follow a family around the
world okay there you go well I think
somebody should be so afraid of a shark
that he dies because he's afraid of the
shark okay there you go
well I think that sharks can roar like
lions and I want to see a shark roaring
like a lion there you go
that's what happened with this script I
guarantee it jaws 4 is one of the worst
movies ever made ever by a person ever
got a shark they can travel from New
York to the Bahamas just because it has
a grudge against a family because three
of his other shark buddies blew up once
it has Ellen Brody and her amazing
psychic powers that allow her to know
when a shark is nearby and to have
flashbacks to memories that she never
witnessed and no living person did
witness and let's not forget that the
shark can growl like a fucking lion guys
thank you so much for watching this
hilarious tea review I'm very much
looking forward to bringing you guys
more of these because I've gotten absurd
amounts of requests to do more I'm
really enjoying these and thank you so
much as always forgive me those requests
because it's really cool to be able to
know what you guys are thinking and one
of the biggest ones I got was vampire's
kiss with Nicolas Cage yes that movie is
amazing and that's going to be my next
hilarious 'ti thank you so much as
always for watching guys and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck menage